i would have done this as a proper  unboxing but i'm actually waiting on  several amazon packages so i didn't  realize this was going to be in that  particular one otherwise i would have  filmed myself opening it but  now obviously says not for resale this  is my this is my test print  copy  it's real  it's real and i flipped through it and i  already found some stuff that i need to  fix  that need to be reformatted or  re-centered and  i need to find out figure out a way to  spread the word map across two pages  because it really is too dang small to  read but  um it's really a thing  hopefully i'll have the physical edition  sorted for the june 1st launch